food riots actually usually rebellions
they usually very considered moments
where people are fed up they're hungry
the prices have gone up and they're
angry with the government of being
consistently unable to deliver riot
implies people are being stupid and
crazy and taken to the street rebellion
puts agency and thought back into their
hand so the Arab Spring is an example of
something that was triggered by very
high wheat prices one of the reasons why
people took the streets was around food
and around hunger some of the most
important moments in modern history are
about rebellions around food so a bread
rebellion became the French Revolution a
rebellion against the the British East
India Company's tea policy was the tea
party that said that set off the
American Revolution
we wait for these peaks of hunger to
happen but even if you take the lowball
estimate of the number of people who are
hungry in the world today
850 million people are going hungry
right now it won't be long again before
we see the kinds of spikes in food
prices that again will bring people to
the streets and we're pro traders we'll
be making a great deal of money in the
financial commodity trading around food
the driver is always the same it's
poverty if you are starving in the world
today it's because you don't have enough
money to be able to buy food